ces derniers jours le brésil bat des
records de décès ces scènes ont été
tournées au cimetière formosa de la
grande métropole sans par l'eau autour
des 1200 morts pour plus de trois cent
dix mille cas confirmés de covin des
chiffres sous-estimés qui devrait être
de 10 à 15 fois supérieur selon
plusieurs experts
spielberg nous sommes en train de perdre
la guerre contre le virus disait
autorités de san paolo en ce moment il
gagne la guerre et les prochains jours
seront les plus importants à riom les
installations du stade de foot du
maracana ont été réquisitionnés pour
traiter les patients de l'aco vide
les cariocas sorte mais ils gardent
leurs distances
ils sont aussi très critiques du
président jaillir ball sonar ou le
président français à la blague il a déjà
perdu deux ministres en un mois et dit
n'importe quoi même si le gouvernement a
pris dès le début les choses plus
sérieusement le pérou est durement
touchée également pour des raisons
inexpliquées plus de cent mille cas et
plus de 3000 morts en plein confinement
et il y en a six frappes et convaincu
les loups si les chiffres sont si élevés
dit le président c'est parce que nous
avons beaucoup testé il prévoit quand
même un des confinement dans deux jours
l'équateur voisins est aussi durement
touché les gens protestent contre la
gestion d'épidémie par le gouvernement
et contre les mesures d'austérité prises
en raison de la crise économique qui
sévit c'est déjà dans le pays
le chili compte encore relativement peu
de cas et de victimes mais les quartiers
les plus pauvres de la banlieue de
santiago se sont révoltés une fois de
plus malgré les consignes de confinement
sévère le gouvernement promet de l'aide
alimentaire
enfin émeutes de la faim également dans
la région de cochabamba en bolivie les
travailleurs du secteur informel
protestent contre le confinement parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus gagner décemment
leur vie
jean michel leprince sera du canada